saludos en directo América de Francia 24
me acompaña en el estudio más Romero
salamar bienvenida buena mañana de
martes hoy hablamos de los hábitos
saludables que Todos queremos Pero
difícil de lograr y de una nueva
herramienta que nos puede ayudar a tomar
estas decisiones te puede hacer más
fácil esto que dices que no es tan fácil
de lograr Porque primero además de la
decisión hace falta saber cuáles son
estos hábitos saludables sabemos que
aquí en este espacio de salud hemos
tenido muchas dudas también a veces no
alrededor de que es bueno que es malo y
esta Pues esta herramienta desarrollada
por el Instituto para la evaluación y
las métricas de la salud nos puede
ayudar se llama el peso de la evidencia
y publicaron sus resultados en nature
básicamente compilan decenas de estudios
y mediciones y arrojan una una un dato
no que apoya o no Una correlación entre
una condición o un hábito y un riesgo no
vendemos veíamos aquí esas estrellas no
el nivel más bajo de estrellas cuando le
dan unas estrellas que no hay evidencia
que haya ninguna relación entre un
hábito y una enfermedad En cambio cuando
hay cinco estrellas pues muestra el
contrario no que sí que la hay una
evidencia muy fuerte en medio y todo un
gradiente se considera que a partir de
las dos estrellas Pues ya hay una
correlación y cuando hay unas que
realmente es no hay evidencia no Por
ahora se han hecho con cuatro hábitos o
cuatro condiciones o entre ellos por
ejemplo fumar también a comer vegetales
y carne roja y en total se han estudiado
más de 50 vínculos entre estas cuatro
pues estas cuatro condiciones y varias
enfermedades se pueden observar todos en
la página Health data.org y Esperamos
que se vaya aplicando en muchos cambios
para ir reduciendo esta confusión que
existe sobre todo en el campo de las
dietas no donde un día sale un estudio
diciendo que algo es bueno al otro día
sale que algo Es malo y eso pues nos
deja todos normalmente con mucha
confusión y mientras más uno esté
informado mejores decisiones se toma no
aplica para todo en la vida Cuáles son
los hallazgos más más destacables
gracias a esta nueva herramienta por
ejemplo la investigación alrededor del
tabaco
no aclara Tantas dudas Porque todos
sabemos hay bastante consenso en que es
malo no hay asociaciones por ejemplo
obviamente de cinco estrellas con el
cáncer de pulmón Aunque
sorprendentemente de una estrella es
decir poca correlación en la asociación
entre el tabaco y el asma esa zona de
las cosas que más nos sorprendió al
revisar los datos pero vamos de nuevo al
tema de las dietas que siempre es el que
más dolores de cabeza da evaluaron por
ejemplo si comer vegetales y en qué
cantidad Tiene efectos para proteger la
salud y en general vemos que sí hay una
correlación dos tres estrellas en varios
casos no es decir por ejemplo tanto para
proteger de accidentes cardiovasculares
isquémicos que es cuando no llega sangre
al cerebro y se muere una parte de
tejido cerebral también de enfermedades
coronarias en general Sí sí podemos
decir después de haber que hayan
revisado cantidad de datos no de decenas
de estudios que tener una dieta rica en
vegetales nos ayuda a proteger de varias
de varias enfermedades en cambio sucede
algo un poco distinto con el tema de la
carne roja que también fue un gran
debate desde hace unos años se le
hachacado esta eti de carcinógena de que
provoca cáncer y esta herramienta
muestra que pues relativamente no vemos
una correlación de dos estrellas aumenta
un riesgo 63% en cáncer colorrectal o
cáncer de seno en cambio en accidentes
pues cerebrovasculares lo mismo que
decíamos no el infarto pues vemos que
queda igual que no hay ninguna
correlación una sola estrella entonces
bueno Esto nos puede servir para no
dejarnos llevar como nos pasa muchas
veces con altos con los nuevos titulares
con estudios chiquitos esto nos ayuda a
tener una idea más grande y nos puede
ayudar tanto para desarrollar políticas
públicas como para saber qué hacer
nosotros todo moderado No Consumo
moderado de los alimentos creo que está
muy bien cambiamos ahora el tema porque
volvemos a hablar de la pandemia 19 que
no se ha ido y por supuesto las vacunas
tan importantes para combatirla
novedades de Oxford y astrazenecamar sí
estaban desarrollando una vacuna nasal
contra el 19 y los resultados en fase 1
no han sido tan prometedores escuchemos
a pesar de un perfil de seguridad
aceptable la capacidad de generar una
respuesta inmune de la vacuna en este
estudio fue insuficiente para seguir con
el desarrollo clínico del actual
formulación el desarrollo de plataformas
tecnológicas para una vacunación sin
agujas protectora y segura sigue siendo
una prioridad para la respuesta contra
el Coby 19 y otras enfermedades el
estudio se hizo con 30 pacientes y
vieron que todos dieron resultados como
decían moderados o leves no no había
tantos anticuerpos en la mucosa nasal
que es lo que se intenta en este tipo de
vacunas si tenían era un nivel poco
superior al de que te da la infección de
Kobe 19 y definitivamente inferior a la
vacuna inyectable pues típica que hemos
estado usando en los últimos dos años
sin embargo Pues los investigadores
dijeron que iban a seguir investigando
con otras formulaciones para ver si
pueden desarrollar una vacuna parecida
en el futuro brevemente marco en este
fallo estracénica de astracénica que
panorama queda entonces en investigación
de las vacunas sin agujas Pues aquí
entramos de nuevo en esa geopolítica de
las vacunas porque en el tema las
vacunas nasales del mundo occidental
digamos que va un poco y más
con este fallo ahora este tropiezo de
astrazeneca que lo pone en desventaja no
porque en China se aprobó un refuerzo de
cansino que es como un nebulizador que
convierte en spray el líquido de la
vacuna que ya existía en India biotec
también consiguió en una vacuna que se
administra por dosis en la nariz El
problema es que estas vacunas no están
aprobadas en muchos países Pues de
Europa Estados Unidos también de hecho
de América Latina y hará falta esperar o
que estas vacunas se aprueben en
nuestros países o que farmacéuticas como
astracénica de la mano con Oxford
desarrollen las suyas propias y se
aprueben en estas regiones mal como
siempre Gracias por toda la información
de salud por el momento Muchas gracias a
ti Raúl y qué